congratulations on season two i watched
it last night and let me say i'm so
excited to see you guys in album mode
yeah
uh are the lyrics going to be as insane
as season one
well yes and no yes and no because
season one
was the insanity of the 90s which is a
particular
kind of insanity so i think we're we're
peeling back some of the misogyny at
least which i think makes it season one
a particular kind of insane sometimes we
over correct the mistake of misogyny
which i think is hilarious so i think
what's the same is that it's it's
hilarious yeah um but yeah but you know
it's now this music is coming from us as
opposed to being put in our mouths
it's just fun it's fun to see really
brilliant songs and they're brilliant
sometimes because of what's strange
about this yes what's trying too hard
maybe about them you know but they're
always catchy and there's always some
layer that i missed the first time i
looked at him there's always something
i'm like oh
i feel that way about this show as a
whole i let i
watch it i like to watch it a few times
because they're so it's so dense it's so
densely written and it's so fast-paced
you can always see something again that
you mentioned yeah i mean we get a taste
of it in that first episode with
momentum
gloria
it's our moment it's your moment and
let's just say the fact this is a huge
hit did you think when you started in
season one that critics and audiences
would absolutely fall in love with it
i don't know that you ever think that
because yeah i hope yeah you hope so i
think the main thing you do is you think
do i love it and you know regardless of
how this goes will this be
a good thing to live in the world and
then you just pray that it works out
after that um i have to say i loved this
show so much when we were doing it i i
just couldn't imagine that it would be
loved um anywhere similar to as much as
i love it it was just gave each one of
us so much we've talked about it so much
with each other of just what a gift this
show was to each one of our lives when
it showed up and so
yeah you make something that you're
you're this invested in and you really
hope that it is
resonant for other people in the same
way it is for you and yeah we're lucky
we want a season
three always been happy to go back to
work
and that's what it is it's the chemistry
between all of you guys the friendship
and i know you guys must hang out with
each other even offset that was crazy
the first time we ever went out off set
together all four of us was last night
what because it's been covered when we
were actually shooting
and uh
and everybody goes to their everyone has
10 million things going on so we don't
get as much but we would we would it's
just i think what adds to the chemistry
is the fact that it's our hang yeah it's
our opportunity to like physically we're
together all the time on the phone but
we our physical ability to be you know
preen each other and be around each
other is when we're on set and i think
that you know comes across
and it made me think you know it's a
hard industry to make it right it's you
know you have this journey you had this
career who was that person that held
your hand that took care of you that was
your advocate to say keep going
oh gosh everybody and i had a i had a
few all right one that one person who is
no longer with me is one of my best
friends and my first manager my tour
manager
my best friend chad joseph so he passed
away right before we started shooting
season one which is part of why this was
such a balm for me um to get to go to
work and to laugh
but he was you know we were roommates
after college he was the one staying up
at night
with the email list and burning cds
and
you know
he was just believed in me and it was uh
a gift i could never repay
and so yeah he's watching over from a
different place now but yeah he was
definitely someone i i will never ever
ever forget
and renee you was there
you know um i um
i feel like every step of the way i
probably couldn't say any one particular
person for fear of um
of you know kind of not acknowledging
somebody else's contribution starting
with my family yeah and just you know i
come from a family of uh you know what i
think it's left brain people everybody's
scientists and mathematicians and uh
just the fact that they could understand
a person that was you know walking
around with a brush in her hand singing
all the time you know and and think that
you know i don't i don't know that they
thought i could do anything else but
regardless of why
um just the fact that not only did they
support me doing it but they always
taught me i think how to find people
that were i think good examples in terms
of modeling the behavior but also
just not wasting on time on people that
were not trying to help you move forward
right right well said yeah and your
character is the fierce one renee
would you say there's similarities
between you and your character
um i think um in that like sasha fierce
way yeah the fact that i haven't that
you know like that we might need an
ultra alter ego to kind of lean on when
we have to do things that feel bigger
than us um i definitely must have that
person
you know just to go on stage or to stand
up in front of anybody to ever do
anything
i think what's interesting about wiki is
i don't know i don't think she knows
that she doesn't always have to be the
fierce side of herself i think for me um
i'm very well aware that it's something
that only needs to exist in certain
times so that somebody else actually
likes me
um
but uh you know so i actually i learn a
lot about her being the fierce one
because i think it's i think i could
have my fear side out a little bit more
than i do yeah and you know one of the
great things about the show it also
talks about the social media and being
discovered on tick tock so do you guys
find yourself scrolling on tick tock and
are you into social media any in any way
we kind of have to be in the world we
live in yeah i think you have to have
well you don't have to do anything but
you
you say we smart no but i mean
i do you just taught us a lesson we both
do and you know and you know we're you
know not not all of us are really busy
phillips like you know there are people
that are better at us really good at it
yeah phillips is she's really good
she's real but i think for me i think
everybody has to decide for themselves
i think it's a pretty toxic place
kind of in general i'm just d you can
tell them i said it
and i think everyone has to decide for
themselves what's like a healthy amount
because yeah it's it's not i don't think
it's good for them for me i feel like
any it's like anything else it actually
can be the most powerful and amazing
tool in the world i love how it's
empowered artists i love the fact that
you know you don't necessarily have to
wait to be chosen by some group of
people in a small room you can actually
just put your stuff out there and maybe
something can happen um and i love the
platform you know if it's used for good
but like anything you can use the power
in in any one of these ways and i but
what's interesting is to see this group
of women try to use it with every other
possible thing
to get
any attention at all like i love i love
it i love i love it
you